amigos si os soy sincero todavía no sé
si ha sido una buena idea meterse en
este berenjenal pero a veces la
tentación es demasiado fuerte aunque me
da que muchos no os vais a dar palos
hasta detrás de las orejas especialmente
los que no os veáis desde argentina pero
en fin como solemos decir por aquí dicho
y hecho
[Aplausos]
queridos amigos el 'new york times'
acaba de publicar su recomendación de
lugares para visitar en 2019 y entre los
25 primeros destinos se encuentran ni
más ni menos que las malvinas si habéis
escuchado bien no las maldivas sino las
malvinas
[Música]
hablamos de un remoto archipiélago
atlántico sur formado por más de 700
islas y que apenas está habitado por
poco más de 3000 personas un territorio
amigos tan vacío como inhóspito pero que
sin embargo durante todo el siglo 20 se
convirtió en uno de los lugares que más
tensión política causo y que incluso
como sabéis todos llegó a desencadenar
la guerra entre el reino unido y
argentina
[Música]
cuánto
de algo con esto es antes
[Música]
y es que amigos para los argentinos la
cuestión de las malvinas es toda una
cuestión una causa nacional
si eres argentino estoy seguro que desde
niños aprendiendo muy rápido que las
malvinas son argentinas la ocupación
británica es todo un robo un atraco un
latrocinio un expolio en la paz con
hidalguía y el rapaz con honor pero
también dispuestos a estar mentar a
quien se atreva a tocar un metro
cuadrado
[Aplausos]
pues bien tras conocer la propuesta del
york times' de repente nos surgieron
unas cuantas preguntas son realmente las
malvinas argentinas porque les importa
tanto este tema a los argentinos al fin
y al cabo argentina es un país enorme ni
más ni menos que el octavo país más
grande del mundo entonces para quién y
andrés tanta preocupación por este
remoto inhóspito y despoblado
archipiélago pues bien estas son las
preguntas que queremos responder con
este vídeo pero un momento antes de que
os lancéis a nuestro cuello quiero dejar
muy claro que este no es un vídeo contra
argentina ni en favor de los británicos
ni nada por el estilo todo lo contrario
lo que queremos es verter un poco de luz
sobre esta cuestión y por cierto este
vídeo lo hemos preparado con amigos
argentinos y lo primero como no es saber
cómo empezó todo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el origen de una disputa interminable
a comienzos del siglo 19 las entonces
colonias españolas en américa comienzan
a protestar contra el gobierno español
la independencia de los eeuu y la
revolución francesa encendería en un
deseo de independencia y libertad que ya
nadie conseguiría a pagar
finalmente en 1808 la invasión
napoleónica de españa' y el
desmantelamiento del poder de madrid se
convirtió en el pistoletazo de salida
para una carrera que daría lugar a la
américa latina' que hoy todos conocemos
de esta forma el 25 de mayo del año 1810
apenas dos años más tarde de la
ocupación francesa de españa' el cabildo
de la ciudad de buenos aires decidió
sustituir al virrey del río de la plata
por la primera junta de gobierno por el
primer gobierno patrio amigos había
comenzado un camino una revolución que
sólo terminaría seis años más tarde con
la proclamación de independencia el día
9 de julio de 1816 de las provincias
unidas del río de la plata' y ojo porque
aquí es donde surge en la primera
confusión
[Música]
y es que se suele pensar que el
virreinato del río de la plata' creado
en 1776 por el rey carlos tercero de
españa era lo que hoy conocemos como
argentina pero amigos esto no es del
todo así veréis me explico el virreinato
del río de la plata' incluía no sólo a
lo que hoy conocemos como argentina
también uruguay bolivia y paraguay
pero vale puede que os estáis
preguntando pero enrique qué tiene que
ver todo esto con si las malvinas son o
no argentinas pues el caso amigos es que
como veis todos estos territorios
formaban parte igual que las malvinas
del virreinato del río de la plata sin
embargo no creo que hoy encontréis a
muchos argentinos reclamando la
soberanía sobre paraguay bolivia o
incluso uruguay así que como veis el
hecho de que las malvinas fueran o no
parte de este virreinato no debería ser
particularmente relevante más aún cuando
estamos hablando de un territorio que
hasta la consolidación de la soberanía
británica estuvo acostumbrado a pasar de
mano en mano
[Música]
de mano en mano de jugada en jugada
la historia de las malvinas es mucho más
simple y más corta de lo que algunos
podrías pensar
veréis hasta a mediados del siglo 18
estas islas nunca fueron ocupadas de
forma permanente y los primeros en
hacerlo no fueron ni los británicos ni
los españoles sino los franceses entre
el año 1764 y 1833 las islas pasaron de
manos francesas a manos españolas luego
a manos inglesas más tarde de nuevo a
manos españolas y por último desde 1833
estas islas han estado bajo soberanía
británica
[Música]
en total para que lo tengamos claro
desde que fueron ocupadas de forma
permanente las malvinas han estado algo
más de 40 años bajo sobre mi española y
más de 180 años bajo soberanía británica
pero un momento entonces por qué
argentina la reclama con tanto ímpetu
pues amigos la respuesta está en que
tras la revolución de mayo que daría
lugar a la independencia de las
provincias unidas del río de la plata'
básicamente argentina las autoridades
locales comenzaron a enviar expediciones
a estas islas que consideraban a todas
luces con propias sin embargo aquí es
donde se produce una enorme controversia
porque más allá de la versión argentina
que dice que los ingleses les
arrebataron en 1833 parte de su
territorio lo cierto es que en aquel
momento argentina todavía era un país en
formación apenas cinco años antes
también habían perdido uruguay hasta
1862 es decir casi tres décadas después
de la ocupación británica argentina no
contó ni siquiera con un presidente
nacional o un presidente para el
conjunto de los argentinos
en otras palabras en 1833 cuando los
ingleses retomaron el control no había
un gobierno nacional argentino el país
no había terminado de formarse y por
supuesto no existía algo así como una
armada nacional incluso aunque resulte
difícil de creer entre 1852 y 1860 el
mismísimo estado de buenos aires- se
separó de la confederación argentina
[Música]
pero esto en sí mismo tampoco es nada
extraordinario la historia se construye
a partir de cambios continuos en las
reglas de juego bajo un prisma histórico
las soberanías van y vienen cambian
continuamente
ahora bien es evidente que la historia
se puede interpretar y leer de muchas
maneras distintas precisamente por eso
muchos argentinos legítimamente
defienden que cuando los ingleses
recuperaron las malvinas estas eran
parte de lo que hoy conocemos como
argentina y que por tanto son territorio
argentino pero amigos han pasado casi
190 años sabéis cuántas personas de
origen argentino viven en las malvinas
apenas 18 personas
de hecho las malvinas así casi 10 veces
más chilenos que argentinos sin embargo
a pesar de ello llegó la guerra
[Música]
e
una guerra inesperada
[Música]
desde que los británicos retomaron el
control de las malvinas argentinas ha
tenido como empeño número uno recuperar
las de hecho ya en 1888 se empezaron a
publicar mapas que incluyen a estas
islas dentro del territorio argentino
sin embargo amigos a pesar de ello lo
cierto es que hasta la segunda guerra
mundial no hubo grandes reclamos de
ninguna de las partes y es que por aquel
entonces argentina e inglaterra eran dos
países bastante amigos de hecho
argentina era el país de américa latina
que más inversiones directas e
indirectas recibía de inglaterra
pero tras la segunda guerra mundial
cambió todo las relaciones comerciales
entre ambos países ya no eran tan
importantes la llegada de perón al poder
hizo que su discurso nacionalista y
antiimperialista tuviera cada vez más
fuerza y la onu recientemente creada
puso su atención en los procesos de
descolonización
en 1965 tras la resolución 2065 de las
naciones unidas- que invitaba a las
partes a negociar la soberanía de las
islas en apenas dos años la situación
dio un giro de 180 grados en 1967
londres trasladó al gobierno argentino
que estaba dispuesto a ceder la
soberanía sobre las malvinas pero eso sí
puso sobre la mesa una condición había
que respetar los deseos de los kelpers
que es como se conoce a los habitantes
de las islas y amigos éstos se opusieron
frontalmente a cualquier traspaso de
soberanía de hecho se movilizaron
activamente contra esta posibilidad
creando lo que se conoció como el
falklands lobby
y ojo porque en aquel momento todo
apuntaba a que el gobierno británico
estaba dispuesto a entregar o al menos
compartir la soberanía sobre las
malvinas a cambio de determinados
acuerdos comerciales pero es que fueron
los propios habitantes de las islas
quienes impidieron esa posibilidad
el pragmatismo de mediados de los 60
probablemente habría conducido al
gobierno británico a transferir la
soberanía de las falkland si no hubiera
sido por el lobby de las falklands
surgido para contrarrestar la presión de
las demandas argentinas
clive ellerby investigador inglés autor
de la obra round of the falklands lobby
y hombre digo yo que algo tendrán que
decir los habitantes de las islas y así
de esta forma es como llegamos al 2 de
abril de 1982
[Música]
junto a american que un pueblo con
voluntad pueblo argentino
si quieren venir que vengan se presentan
en la batalla
[Aplausos]
y ese día un oscuro gobierno militar
desprestigiado y represor sin apoyo
local y responsable de una de las épocas
más terribles de la historia moderna de
argentina con miles de desaparecidos con
presos políticos y una enorme crisis
económica tomó una decisión lograr el
apoyo del pueblo alimentando el fervor
patriótico
el gobierno argentino amigos tomó la
decisión de invadir las malvinas
en aquel momento las autoridades
argentinas esperaban que tras la
invasión se llegara una especie de
acuerdo diplomático con el reino unido-
sin embargo no contaron con la
determinación de esta mujer
[Música]
margaret thatcher la primera ministra
del reino unido que estuvo dispuesta a
librar una guerra a miles de kilómetros
de distancia el desenlace fue terrible
y estable
life
[Música]
la superioridad tecnológica y militar
del ejército británico junto a las
negligentes decisiones del gobierno
militar argentino que había llevado a
cabo la invasión con soldados muy
jóvenes con poca preparación militar y
mal equipados hizo que el reino unido-
recobrar a las islas poco más de dos
meses al final una vez más una decisión
política de un gobierno tirano terminó
con una guerra tan innecesaria como
inútil que le costó la vida a cientos de
personas
amigos sabemos lo difícil que son este
tipo de situaciones y con este vídeo no
queremos decir que el reino unido tenga
más o menos derechos que argentina sobre
las malvinas lo que hemos querido es
poner sobre la mesa una realidad y es
que a lo largo de la historia los
territorios han pasado de unas manos a
otras continuamente durante más de 300
años lo que hoy es argentina estuvo bajo
dominio español y durante más de 180
años las malvinas han sido británicas
que importa aquí quien tuvo razón hace
200 años no es acaso más importante
pensar en lo que tenemos hoy y en lo que
está por venir en fin es sólo una
reflexión sé que no es el tema más
cómodo pero creo sinceramente que
teníamos que hablar de ello ahora bien
un momento nos queda una pregunta en el
tintero por qué tanto empeño en las
malvinas y tienen de especial estas
islas porque son características amigos
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
lo vamos a hacer en un próximo vídeo así
que ya sabéis no olvidéis suscribiros a
visual política pero antes de terminar
una pregunta qué crees que debe ocurrir
con las malvinas déjanos tu respuesta en
los comentarios y también en esta
encuesta un saludo y hasta la próxima
que vengan a presentar la nueva tasa
[Aplausos]
[Música]